you
I love this movie this movie rocks and
if you hate it
well you're wrong
I'm I'm sorry that was that was wrong of
me I apologize
The Chronicles of Riddick
you probably already figured this out
but I love this movie I love all the
Riddick stuff actually I think that it's
far better property in mythos than it
gets credit for and that's why I want to
talk about it at the same time though
I'm not going to sugarcoat it there
there are problems big problems first a
history lesson The Chronicles of Riddick
is the second feature-length film in a
multimedia franchise spanning
live-action cinema animation books and
video games the series began with pitch
black a tight little independent horror
film released in 2000 shot for around
twenty five million dollars pitch black
on the whole did quite well for itself
drawing in around 50 million just from
the box office as far as independent
films go that's that's a smashing
success around the same time the matrix
a medium budget sci-fi film had pulled
in over 700 million and was already
slated for two sequels to be released by
Warner Brothers in 2003 wetting the
mainstream appetite for science fiction
top it off
Vin Diesel followed up pitch black with
The Fast and the Furious which pulled in
over 200 million dollars at the box
office so in 2001 science fiction was
marketable and Vin Diesel was marketable
because of that something amazing
happened Universal Pictures gave David
to E and Vin Diesel over 100 million
dollars to make a sequel and in turn
they delivered unto us the Wonder that
is the Chronicles of Riddick
Universal God yeah most of their money
back well Wow Wow
okay in in the end they got their money
back just just just not from box office
receipts the film barely broke even now
in the scale of things it made a little
over 100 million dollars which is double
what pitchblack pulled in the only
problem was that it also cost a little
over 100 million to make see it turns
out that all the things that make this
movie interesting and unique are also
the kind of things that tend to alienate
a mainstream audience doubly so for an
audience already cooled by The Matrix
Revolutions so by the time Riddick was
released in mid 2004 a lot of the
audience just kinda
I I don't feel like I need to spend all
that much time talking about all the
problems just because they're all kind
of obvious this isn't one of those
situations where I tell you something is
bad but then reveal that it's bad for
reasons that are kind of obscure The
Chronicles of Riddick is bad for almost
all the reasons that you think it's bad
the plot is helter skelter the story
editing is uneven characters repeatedly
make stupid decisions some of the
effects are terrible and the dialogue is
muddy and often hilariously bad it's
been a long time since I smelled
beautiful over and over again instead of
shooting him with their guns the
Necromongers charger Riddick with melee
weapons even though he clearly
outclasses them I mean the first time it
kind of makes sense when Riddick like
challenges the one guy to a duel cuz
like it's a duel okay I can buy that but
then they take him back to their ship to
scan his brain and to do this they turn
on like super gravity and we see that he
can't get out of this right so look at
this room he's down in a pit stuck to
the floor with super gravity and his
only weapon is a knife that's also stuck
to the floor and they find out he's a
fury in and people are all kill him kill
him but instead of just shooting him
like a million times from up above they
shut off the super gravity so that dudes
can charge him with their giant pickaxes
thing and they get predictably like
stabbed in the face
so yeah plot contrivance --is there's
more but it's all just regular nonsense
like outrunning sunrise and looking
really pretty well living in a triple
max prison and you know what I'm kind of
okay with all of that it's cheesy and
campy at times what is that
I'll kill you with my teacup
but that's part of what I love and it
all ties in to what makes it Riddick it
great see Riddick is different unusual
but it's also built out of some old
material the story of Chronicles of
Riddick is basically a retelling of
Conan the Destroyer Riddick is Conan in
space and it draws on a lot of that
classic pulp fiction worldview you have
a barbaric warrior forged in captivity
outcast from proper society a holy man a
mystic woman a doomed love death cult
revenge violence and a running theme of
upsetting the status quo typically
movies of these sorts meaning sci-fi
action movies with budgets north of 100
million dollars follow pretty tightly to
the Joseph Campbell monomyth this is the
hero's journey that you've seen dozens
if not hundreds of times before the hero
is called to action rejects the call
faces supernatural adversity accepts the
call is initiated into a fantastic
secret world is defeated recovers
defeats evil and returns to his people
with power the core themes revolve
around a weak character becoming strong
in the codification of a morally
superior power structure in the triumph
of good over evil
Luke learns to use the force and blows
up the Death Star
neo becomes the one in defeats Smith so
on and so forth there's more to it than
that but the important thing to note
here is first the transformation a weak
character becomes strong and second the
triumph of good over evil Riddick
instead starts with a character who is
already fantastic and exceptional when
we first meet him in pitch-black
Richard B Riddick is already stronger
and faster than most trained soldiers
and he already has a supernatural power
in his ability to see in the dark we
don't see him learn these things or grow
into them
he's already that way and over the
course of the film he doesn't transform
much he learns a few new things about
himself changes a bit his character but
it's not a transformation he doesn't
grow into any new power capacity this
ties into the second point at the end of
The Chronicles of Riddick
he stumbles into power it's not
something he saw or even something he
was encouraged to pursue but rather
something he comes into in the pursuit
of personal goals
rescuing Kira and killing Lord Marshall
rather than re-establishing the status
quo or restoring the world to an
Natural Balance Riddick disrupts the
entire balance of power leaving the
future is one big question mark now you
might have noticed that I haven't
actually done a plot summer yet and
that's kind of intentional this is all
part of one of the other things that I
love so much about the film and that's
the world that it builds this world is
dance lived in and quite alien to our
own to me this is admirable but yeah it
can be hard to follow at times Riddick
is an escaped convict on the run from
bounty hunters he thought he was safe
and hiding so he picks off most of the
crew and scares the captain tombs into
telling him who gave them the lead tooms
tells Riddick that it was an anonymous
tip from the planet of new Mecca which
tips off Riddick that it was probably a
mom one of the two other survivors from
pitch black and the only person who knew
where Riddick was going Riddick steals
the ship and confronts a mom who tells
him about the Necromongers an
interstellar death cult led by the Lord
Marshal who was a half dead supernatural
the Necromongers are coming to convert
or kill everyone in the galaxy on their
search for a place called the underverse
Riddick also finds out the jack the
other survivor from pitch black who's
actually a girl got herself arrested and
thrown into a prison called crematoria
because she was trying to find Riddick
the police tried to rest Riddick he
kills them the Necromongers arrive all
hell breaks loose and Imam is killed in
the skirmish later at this recruitment
rally type thing I don't know Lord
Marshal rips out some guy's soul
everyone's all like what's going on and
then Riddick calls out the killer and
this is where we've got the duel we
talked about this earlier Riddick wins
the fight the ending is set up when lord
marshal hands him the knife and tells
Riddick you keep what you kill dame
Vaako uses sex appeal to learn Riddick
into the Necromonger ship where the
Oracles determined that he's a Furion
Riddick escapes Toombs and his new crew
show up Riddick lets them capture them
he tricks them into taking him to
crematoria where he finds Jack who now
calls herself Kira and they fight off
guards and stuff while tombs and his
crew argue with the guards about how
much bounty they should be getting for
Riddick
but then Lord Vaako and the blond guy
show up people shoot each other Riddick
and some convicts race the guard to the
ship but then Vaako lands there's a
fight Kira's captured blond guy saves
Riddick and reveals he's a fury and two
before killing himself by standing out
in the Sun Riddick takes the ship
infiltrates the Necromonger
five cure has already been converted
fight slurred Marshall almost loses
before Kira saves him she gets thrown
into a spike Vaako attempts a coup but
Lord Marshall teleports away right as
Riddick stabs his ghost killing him
Riddick and Kira share a few last words
she dies Riddick takes a timeout on Lord
Marshalls throne Vaco reminds him that
you keep what you kill then all the
Necromongers bow before Riddick they
turn off the planet killer things
credits roll I don't blame you if you
fell behind the Chronicles of Riddick
throws a lot at the audience characters
are carried forward from pitch black
we're told about religions and worlds
and groups of people terminology and
slang or tossed around and the movie
doesn't explain much of it at all there
is no audience surrogate no first day on
the job training that everyone patiently
explains everything - this is a bit of a
noble flaw to me technically
screenwriting 101 it's not the way you
should do things but if you're willing
to put in a bit of effort as a viewer
then it accomplishes something you just
don't get by doing things the right way
on one hand it's alienating to try and
keep up with all the new and strange
information but at the same time the
atmosphere is just that bit more
believable when the characters act like
this is all kind of normal and the world
is more intriguing when you don't have
all the answers this folds into the
film's overall aesthetic both in terms
of story and style now I'm a fan of all
Star Wars and Star Trek but I love The
Chronicles of Riddick looks nothing like
either one of them instead it draws on
the aesthetics of Warhammer heavy metal
Edgar Rice Burroughs Frank Herbert in
borås Vallejo it's a world where the
weird the strange the freaks the kinks
the exotic and the fantastic are common
the heroes are outcasts criminals loners
and minorities fighting back against
whitey in his invasive military death
cult
there is no galactic order no Federation
of Planets just feudal city-states
private prisons bounty hunters and a
whole lot of empty space I love the
armor the weapons of the monolithic
temple ships in the haphazard blend of
magic and space travel even Star Wars
and Star Trek in their vast expanded
universe never got quite as weird quite
as imaginative as Riddick does to top it
off even
with the cheese and the confusion it's
still a really enjoyable really
watchable film is it great art no it's
interesting art though it's different
it's a trashy pulpy load of
anti-establishment wish-fulfillment and
I think it's worth your time in the
words of Pauline Kael the movies are so
rarely great art that if we cannot
appreciate great trash we shouldn't go
at all this my friends is great trash